I'm a rapper and obviously
I do freestyle rap do you say I'm scared
yes no that's okay
there's a lot of white people here and
then I the whitest person Come on talk
about the queen you know the chief
colonizer and
I might as well just be showing off big
diamonds right now and just like look at
this any brown people this is ours not
yours we took this is that you'll take
it back it's it's not real it's a mime
um you are you are allowed to be scared
don't worry
um no I do freestyle rap that's
improvise It's Made Up on the spot it
requires you lovely people to tell me
what you'd like to hear a rap about but
there are some rules because you know
it's hip-hop but British hip-hop so
rules right this is just for your
benefit you can't suggest food or
animals they're the most obvious things
our brains think of and they're too
simple anyone can [ __ ] freestyle
about that we want to make it difficult
number two don't say the first thing in
your brain change it we don't want it to
be a suggestion that's come up before
don't say anything I've mentioned in
this set don't say anything weird and
British right because if you if you're
like oh [ __ ] bangers and mash all
these prayers they don't give a [ __ ]
about our country they don't know what
it means don't the queen and know this
you could be imaginative difficult
creative the best suggestion ever was a
German man who said a day into life of
an Aztec high priest
English boy
beautiful language right
if you are in this section over here
would you like a rapper
baseball baseball what particular aspect
of baseball would you like us to hone in
on home runs home runs thank you very
much for saying it like you were talking
to a toddler as well
home runs Chris when they do a big hit
and it goes very far
home runs thank you very much home runs
at middle middle of the room watch like
a rapper
Eskimo sex where
when it's a suggestion like that I'm
always like oh as a comedian earlier in
the show said something very funny and
you that's not a call back to that is it
that's just something from your Twisted
mind
Eskimo sex Eskimo sex I love it Eskimo
sex section over here would you like a
rap about the Irish famine the Irish
famine foreign
[Applause]
what would you like to have a rap about
the Caribbean oh you said the Caribbean
sorry I never know how to pronounce it
is it technically the Caribbean or the
Caribbean or does it really not matter
it really doesn't matter appreciate that
thank you
um and what what's about what about the
Caribbean or the Caribbean
how about I pay you
cool yeah I mean look they're
uncomfortable but they should be yeah
[ __ ] reparations
um the Caribbean and how they should be
paid now my my little uh kind of you
know English gang here English boy
English dad non-english person
um what what would you like a rap about
Meghan Markle Meghan Markle lovely stuff
yeah cool
cool great I mean
I think I'm the only one in the room
who's excited for this I feel like the
rest of you are going oh this is going
to be the shittest thing we've ever seen
so did you say you can do this is why
American audiences are great because in
England it would be now that someone
would have thrown a glass
and said your [ __ ] [ __ ] man
so it's a wrap made up on the spot about
the Caribbean how they should be paid
about Meghan Markle it's about home runs
about Eskimo sex and about the Irish
famine and do not worry it will not be
anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe curlingly bad as you
are expecting a privately educated
middle class white British boy who did
actually go to Oxford
[Applause]
[ __ ] hate myself right let's drop
this beat and let's uh let's have some
fun this is gonna be nice it's gonna be
nice it's gonna be great
I love that you cheer while we're
spitting this close to the stage sitting
in it that's the British guy chilling
there with his dad by his side American
lady one day be the bride maybe I don't
know if there's a wedding ring oh you
got it right there green card you can
bring home ahead I know you did it for
your jobs mixing the continents all so
odd to the royal family they were like
we'd be heading in the wrong direction
why cause Harry met in wedigan red where
did Megan yeah getting mixed round like
a little finger I see them he picks now
a pretty girl an actress for sure from
the West Coast that's the California
Shore saying oh my gosh the prettiest
lady she makes my dick hard makes my
Ginger boobs crazy but then the queen
she was upset saying Harry why are you
meddling with that skit
don't understand you over here there was
Prince Andrew he was like oh I don't
like her she's mixed race and she's in
her 40s what a wrinkly face because
usually he's naughty with the underage
allegedly you said when I came on stage
but Meghan Markle then again she's the
10 out of 10. like the real Eminem
coming over here I know we're slamming
the queen she was thinking about the
Irish famine there and her dreams I know
it wasn't her fault but hold me down
whose fault was it yes the British crown
well technically they had the
interregnum that's Oliver Cromwell so
pay attention he deposed the Monarch and
said my wish is to break sure there's a
problem for the Irish take all the
potatoes fill them with disease yes go
away all the Irish they leave they were
heading away with the potato blight all
the [ __ ] that we did wasn't really right
they were starving they were causing an
alarm they didn't have food like Lucky
Charms Ah that's a little Irish thing
important anybody see a tiny green
little Leprechaun not lost on me yeah
you know that I felt it go off to Boston
not to watch the Celtics but whatever
your baseball team's got a name for I've
never watched that abomination of a
sport
if I still find it wholehearted even if
they went batter up and slapped a home
run out of the park out of Fenway out of
the night you can't see the ball it's
not lit by the Light it travels to a far
Arc clearing the car park the parking
lot Americans This lot you gotta
translate it hitting the ball 45 degree
that's the perfect launching angle it
goes out of there yet you can't even see
him British people season all the
Caribbean they were like oh yes yo look
Brothers we're coming over here cut down
these sugars causing you pain give us
the cane make the rub then trade it with
Spain prove it to Portugal move it round
resource such a sad thing with the
beautiful Shores yes definitely be paid
the Caribbean Nations Jamaica Dominica
give the reparations but the lasting The
Finisher mad respect the one that you
guys select with the Eskimo sex
everything else that we got tonight was
really edgy but y'all is really nice
that's an ice pun get it that's my goal
I want to slip it in the hole and I'm at
the North Pole be careful don't let us
suck your dick cause it's so called that
the Eskimo tongue would stick
[Applause]